am 14 oktober 1993 ist die damals 16
jährige nicole schaller auf dem
nachhauseweg gegen 22 uhr 45 steigt in
der nähe ihres elternhauses in dortmund
aus dem bus doch zu hause kommt sie nie
an ein fremder mann soll ihr gefolgt
sein
am nächsten morgen findet eine
zeitungsbotin die leiche in einem
gebüsch unweit einer grundschule nicole
wurde missbraucht und erdrosselt einen
tatverdächtigen ermittelt die polizei
erst 25 jahre später im juni 2018
eine haut shopper auf dem körper hat die
beamten auf die spur von ralf h aus
münster gebracht möglich wurde das durch
eine neuartige analyse von dna spuren
war wird festgenommen und muss sich ab
dezember 2018 vor dem landgericht
dortmund verantworten
in handschellen wird er in den saal
geführt er verdeckt sein gesicht die
schreckliche tat wird ralf h im laufe
des prozesses abstreiten
joachim und sigrid schaller die eltern
der toten verfolgen den prozess als
nebenkläger sie waren zum tatzeitpunkt
in den herbstferien 1993 in holland
urlaub hatten noch mit ihrer tochter
telefoniert und sich auf das wiedersehen
gefreut doch dann wurde nicole ermordet
obwohl der fall so lange zurückliegt
sind beide eltern in psychologischer
betreuung im märz 2020 platz dann
plötzlich der prozess am 27
verhandlungstag eine richterin war
langfristig erkrankt im august sollte
der prozess von vorn beginnen
doch nun wurde ralf h überraschend aus
der untersuchungshaft entlassen das
entschied das oberlandesgericht in hamm
ein tatverdacht bestehe weiterhin
und obwohl lebenslanger haft drohen sei
die untersuchungshaft nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig so das gericht dem
angeklagten seien die
verfahrensverzögerungen durch die justiz
und zuletzt aufgrund der korona pandemie
nicht anzulasten
das neue verfahren beginnt nun am 14
august vor dem landgericht in dortmund
über diesen fall spreche ich jetzt mit
arabella profi ist anwältin der
nebenklage vertritt also die familie
schaller in diesem prozess ja guten tag
frau pooth deshalb verfahren hat hier
nun eine überraschende wendung genommen
was ist da genau passiert
das verfahren ist derzeit ausgesetzt wir
haben ja praktisch eine runde schon
hinter uns
das verfahren musste dann eben komplett
ausgesetzt werden weil fristen
überschritten wurden weil eine richterin
erkrankt ist dann sollte das verfahren
ursprünglich eigentlich im frühjahr
wieder starten
das war allerdings nicht möglich
aufgrund der korona pandemie dann haben
wir einige termine für juli bereits
abgestimmt da ist dann allerdings ein
kleiner fehler des gerichts wohl
passiert ist waren akten zeitweise
verschwunden
deswegen konnte das verfahren dann
erneut nicht starten und jetzt haben wir
einen termin für den vierten augusto das
verfahren dann komplett neu beginnen
soll und ich hoffe dass er stattfindet
wir gehen denn die eltern von nicole
scheller damit um dass der mutmaßliche
mörder ihrer tochter jetzt wieder frei
herumläuft genau und zwar habe ich heute
um ich glaube 14 uhr 37 ein fax bekommen
vom oberlandesgericht haben
das war ein beschluss und nach diesem
beschluss geht eben der angeklagte aus
der untersuchungshaft entlassen
das war für uns alle ein schock
begründet wurde das damit dass gesagt
wurde das verfahren ist zu lange
verzögert worden aufgrund von umständen
die der angeklagte selber nicht zu
vertreten hatte
wir hatten hier ja nicht gerade schon
geschildert hatte einige punkte die von
der justiz nicht so ganz glatt gelaufen
sind
eine richterin war erkrankt da kann
jemand was für aber eben auch der
angeklagte nicht das ist nun mal so dann
sind akten weg das ist wieder was wo ich
denke sollte eigentlich nicht passieren
corona pandemie da konnte jetzt niemand
was dafür
und all dies hat natürlich das verfahren
extrem verzögert der angeklagte sind
schon lange in untersuchungshaft aber
trotzdem hätte ich nicht erwartet dafür
entlassen wird denn immerhin
haben wir hier meiner meinung nach einen
ganz ganz dringenden tatverdacht einen
ganz erheblichen tatverdacht und ich
erwarte dass er am ende des verfahrens
auch tatsächlich wegen mordes verurteilt
wird und wenn dann eben eine lebenslange
freiheitsstrafe
dem gegenüber steht die der angeklagte
zu erwarten hat dann relativiert sich
diese zeit der untersuchungshaft wieder
die ihr auf eine freiheitsstrafe immer
auch angerechnet wird und deshalb kann
ich die entscheidung rechtlich dann doch
nicht so ganz
ja frau kurz so viel zuwendung in diesem
verfahren noch mal die frage wie gehen
denn die eltern von nicole schaller
jetzt damit um dass der mörder ihrer
tochter frei herumläuft
also ich muss sagen ich im kleinen stadt
jetzt seit zwei jahren und habe mit
sollers schon einiges erlebt aber so wie
heute habe ich sie eigentlich noch nicht
erlebt sie waren also vollkommen am
boden zerstört herr schaller hat am
telefon zu mir gesagt frau bot ich weiß
gar nicht was ich machen soll meine frau
zittert und kriegt ihr gleichen
nervenzusammenbruch er selber ist
geschockt und fassungslos und hat zu mir
gesagt also dass sowas vor einem
deutschen gericht passieren kann dass es
ihm unerklärlich und auch alle in
schallers freundes und bekanntenkreis
die ja immer regelmäßig auch hinten im
zuschauerraum sitzen sind also
fassungslos welche juristischen
möglichkeiten gibt es denn diesen
beschluss jetzt anzufechten
also im prinzip gibt es da jetzt für uns
jedenfalls erstmal nicht so richtige
möglichkeiten ich meine natürlich könnte
ich jetzt beantragt werden seitens der
staatsanwaltschaft einen haftbefehl
wieder zu erlassen aber das hätte ja
oder sehr wenig erfolgversprechend da
könnte man also kann man jetzt im moment
erstmal wenig gegen thun frau pooth
vielen herzlichen dank für diese
auskünfte und bei mir im studio ist
jetzt michael engelberg du begleitet
diesen fall
sag uns malteser fall ist ja von einem
erfolg nach 25 jahren jetzt eigentlich
zu pleiten pech und pannen geworden oder
wie schätzt du das 1
patricia also man muss natürlich sagen
dass mit der mit der aufhebung des
haftbefehls für die eltern ein weiterer
ein weiterer schlag ins gesicht passiert
ist denn sie haben sehr sehr lange
darauf gewartet dass es überhaupt
ermittlungserfolge gibt
dann ist vor zwei jahren eine damals
gefundene dna-spur mit neuester technik
noch einmal untersucht worden
dann ist man auch frage kommen da haben
die eltern natürlich gehofft dass sie
jetzt nach 25 jahren mit diesem fall
abschließen können dann hat der prozess
begonnen 27 verhandlungstage sie haben
immer wieder diesem mann ins gesicht
gesehen es gab auch dialoge ralf hat von
anfang an seine unschuld beteuert hat
gesagt dass die eltern doch auch wissen
möchten wer ihre tochter umgebracht hat
der hat anträge gestellt er hat
natürlich versucht seine unschuld zu
beweisen was legitim ist als angeklagter
und jetzt war man kurz auch vor dem
urteil und jetzt ist das ganze platz und
es fängt tatsächlich vom neuen von
neumann und der mutmaßliche mörder ihrer
tochter ist jetzt bis zur nächsten
verhandlung frei er kaum vorzustellen
was in eltern in so einer situation vor
sich geht wut verzweiflung trauer du
hast ja mit den eltern von nicole
schaller gesprochen wie fühlen sie sich
derzeit also wir haben über die ganze
verhandlungsdauer gesprochen und man
muss sagen dass sie sehr sehr angespannt
sind es gab immer eine eine betreuung
neben sigrid schaller die immer auf sie
auf sie eingeredet hat weil sie für sie
das unheimlich schwer war
joachim schall muss man sagen der stand
auch die ganze zeit richtig unter strom
wenn der refrain schon angesehen hatte
da merkte man schon wieder innerlich
bebte und als es dann die dialoge gab
als er dann sagte sie wollen doch auch
wissen wer denn wer ihre tochter
umgebracht hat dann musste man musste
man joachim scheller tatsächlich auf dem
stuhl festhalten für die eltern ist das
natürlich eine absolute vollkatastrophe
sie haben gehofft abschließen zu können
und jetzt muss man damit rechnen dass
wenn der prozess im august wieder
aufgerollt wird also quasi von vorne
beginnt ja dass sie den mutmaßlichen
mörder ihrer tochter auf dem gang auf
dem weg ins gericht in den gerichtssaal
begegnen und das sind absoluter albtraum
du begleitet diesen prozess ja schon
länger jetzt gab es ja mehrere pannen
vielleicht kannst du uns darüber nochmal
berichten also nicht nur corona macht
dem ganzen jetzt ein strich durch die
rechnung was ist denn da sonst noch vor
gefallen also jeder der schon mal post
bekommen hat weiß dass die irgendwann
mal auch
irgendwie hatten kommen werden paket
bestellt dann kommt es beim nachbarn
oder kommt gar nicht an so ist das auch
mit einer akte gewesen wie wichtig war
für den prozess die wahl kurzer zeit
verschwunden
das kann man dem angeklagten nicht
anlasten er hat sich vernünftig auf die
verhandlungen vorzubereiten keine akten
keine verhandlung also so einfach ist
das das ist natürlich extrem bitter
aber in dem fall wurden nicht zu ändern
dass eine an eine richterin plötzlich
erkrankt auch völlig menschlich und dann
kommt corona da konnte halt auch keiner
mit rechnen
und man muss auch die anwälte von ralf h
verstehen sie ihr deren job ist es denn
man aus der u haft zu bekommen die haben
alle juristischen mittel ausgeschöpft
dass der erste strafsenat hat
entschieden dass die u-haft nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig ist deshalb hat man ihn
freigelassen auf der anderen seite die
richter des landgerichts in dortmund der
präsident und der pressesprecher
ich glaube dass die dieses verhalten
überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen können
weil ein dringender tatverdacht
weiterhin besteht und bei einer
verurteilung die möglichkeit einer
lebenslangen freiheitsstrafe gegeben ist
also ich glaub für alle beteiligten eine
katastrophe außer für magath der nach
zwei jahren über zwei jahren
untersuchungshaft erst mal wieder
frische luft draußen genießen kann ja
ein unglaublicher fall michael engelberg
begleitet diesen fall wir bleiben dann
natürlich weiter dran vielen herzlichen
dank für deinen besuch im studio
bitteschön